[Music]
streets away from the scene of her death
a service dedicated to the memory of
olivia pratt corbell
for a vicar who spent the week trying to
soothe a community in shock reflecting
on the pain olivia's family must be
feeling was almost too much
what do we say or do when something so
unspeakably horrific as may there
happens in our own community even worse
than method of a child who was in what
should have been the safest place in the
world in their own home whether
with their mum
here they've spent the week saying
prayers lighting candles and sending
their condolences
i think it's disbelief and shock and
fear but there's hope you know people
will come together and i really hope
that the people that have done this get
brought to justice
words fail you just don't can't
comprehend it to be honest
it's just
why are people doing this why are they
carrying these knives guns and
destroying lives and we just asked them
to draw the message from their sunday
school a simple one and i can see that
one of them
the area outside her home is still taped
off with officers doing everything they
can to move this investigation forward
it's been nearly a week since olivia's
killing and police continue to gather
evidence at the scene the two men have
arrested have been released on bail
police have taken the unusual step of
releasing a video asking for more
information
we've got a nine-year-old girl who won't
celebrate
their 18th birthday
the city's mayor says liverpool can move
past this violence across the whole of
the region actually and much further
beyond that our messages of support
you know liverpool
is not like this this is not a typical
of what happens here um the community
support here is enormous you'll you'll
see
solidarity like nowhere else one of
those messages from a man who drove more
than 200 miles to pay his respects it
just shouldn't be happening
it shouldn't be happening at all
knife crime gun crime everything it's
all it's all got to stop
it's all got to
olivia's life cut short has shocked her
community
but still the police are calling for
help with their investigation to find
her killer shingi maraike sky news
liverpool